philip what's up man how can i help so
i'm 24 and i live with my girlfriend
we're about to have a baby on the way
okay and uh i recently discovered you
guys uh i found you through dave ramsey
and i really liked watching the show he
would help me um
get back to walking with the lord and i
really try to get my life
together again especially my friends
since with a kid but
the problem is uh my girlfriend she
happens to be
uh atheist okay and i love my girlfriend
and i want to marry her so we
uh don't keep living in sin so i'm
worried um as we keep going on and
developing
as a couple that she could keep
undermining me
and not maybe not want me to speak on
the lord so i don't know if it's
okay to marry her uh as she's an eighth
i'm a christian
and she wants to keep waiting as well so
what do you uh suggest i do
you ask me a whole bunch of questions
here and a couple of them
no you're all good bro it is a lot um
all at the outset i'm not gonna tell you
what to do here
okay right um here's
a couple of things you've got a baby on
the way that needs two parents who
love that baby is it a boy or girl um we
don't know yet
okay let's pretend what do you want it
to be i want to be a girl
all right so i'm gonna say it's a little
boy all right so you got this little boy
just to mess with you so um this little
boy needs two parents that love him
okay love him more than anything on
planet earth that show up
every single day that love each other
that talk nicely and respect one another
that um
don't yell and scream and show up and
don't make
drama and deal with the challenges of
this crazy world together
right right that little baby boy needs
that and deserves that and i'm telling
you right now philip he's going to get
that right
yes sir okay so you and your wife have
different belief systems
about religion about god about
fill in the blank
if you have different beliefs that are
tethered to deep
deep values you can make things work
if you don't it's gonna be hard okay
so where do you think she's gonna i'm
gonna be back ask this way
does she regularly undermine you
not regularly but um how does she
undermine you
i say for example i would like to uh
raise my kid
in the church definitely doing that she
would say like uh
she won't want to do that so we'll see
one thing will she prohibit you from
taking your kid to church on a sunday
she hasn't flat out right said it but it
could be a definitely a possibility that
she just probably just said no it
stopped one time
she said like she would rather the kid
asked to go to church and said uh
me straight up taking them well all that
kid's gonna ask for for the first three
or four years
is um a new diaper food
hugs once he turns three or four he's
gonna want to like
i don't know if it's a girl
i don't know i'm not gonna get into it
they're gonna watch tv don't let him do
it dude don't let him do it because then
it just changes everything right
um and don't ever let any of your kids
watch frozen because the rest of your
life will just be frozen related
um here's the thing you all need to get
with a
marriage counselor pronto all right
okay and you may say but i'm not married
we're not even engaged yet whether you
want to or not you are
connected to this woman for the rest of
your life
and what i will ask you for the sake of
that baby is that you all begin to work
together
on values are we going to be people of
integrity are going to be people who
um love our baby are we going to get
over petty stuff are we going to go over
little stuff or big stuff
and that's where i in for you a value
maybe i will not marry someone who does
not believe in god
great then you need to cut the cord on
this
living together let her move on with her
life
and you all figure out with the help of
a counselor what
um joint custody is going to look like
moving forward
okay if you love her and
you all have different beliefs about the
afterlife you'll have very similar
values
you're both people of integrity both
people who respect one another you're
both good human beings
and you believe in god you believe in
jesus and she doesn't
and i don't know why she
let my kid grow kid's three dude kids
too kids don't ask for that kind of
stuff
you teach your kids you let them grow up
and value systems and community systems
and so
that whole conversation gets me
frustrated man but um that's letting
kids run the household
um the same as a kid what do you want
for dinner honey here's what you're
gonna have for dinner right
there's a three-year-old's gonna pick
ice cream and marshmallows every time
and chicken nuggets
and that's why they need parents in
their life to say no i want you to have
structure
and values and broccoli and fill in the
blank but that's a whole other phone
call bro
you all need to get together and find
out what your values are and
some of this like i don't know man she
may just you need to have answers to
those questions
asap okay yes sir
and the sooner you have answers to those
questions
um the more you can make concrete
decisions because what you're trying to
do is have the best of both worlds
you're having a baby with someone that
you probably love and care for is that
fair
yes okay you love her and care for her
and you're
a christian is that right yes sir okay
and she's not and so you've
you're feeling a significant tension is
she feeling this tension at all or she
looking at you like dude what's wrong
with you
why don't we just have this yeah she's
like she's looking at what's the problem
okay so i want you to get with a
counselor because my guess is if she's
looking at you that way your values may
be much more closely aligned than you
think they are
okay and i don't want you to use the
tension of
an upcoming birth of a child i don't
want you to
have the tension of um
she won't marry me right now i don't
want you to then
create this ecosystem where your kid's
gonna be born into a mess of stress
and chaos i also don't want you to get
married
thinking i'll just figure this out later
and that all she'll just come around and
she may not
okay yes sir so do the best you can to
get
real life answers and not just well i
think get real answers
have a somebody that's a professional
that can walk you all to
through this okay and in the process
if you want to um
nobody's ever can like um
convince somebody to their particular
faith by
crushing them in an argument or
threatening them or putting their foot
on their neck right
right like the old scripture they're
gonna know we're christians by the love
we have for each other
the church has lost to that sucker right
and so i don't think relationships are
doomed because
people have different beliefs they are
more complicated and they are hard
but if everybody goes into them with a
sense of mutual respect
then they can be overcome they can also
um not work at all from the outset and
you all just have to be grown ups and
make those decisions
okay but you have to get over the best
of i want all this all at the same time
in the best of both worlds it all works
out for me
okay the reality is you got your
girlfriend pregnant and now things got
accelerated real fast
and y'all are gonna have to make some
real real grown-up decisions real real
fast
okay and no one's gonna get everything
that they want in this deal unless y'all
both decide for the sake of this baby
for the sake of one another we love each
other we're going to continue to learn
and grow in our values our beliefs are
going to shift and change and that's
okay that's called growing up that's
called wisdom
i hope my beliefs change a thousand
times in my lifetime
but i want my values to stay completely
rooted and um
does that make sense yes sir it does
okay
so what's your next step
next step is to go see somebody like a
counselor no your next step is this okay
you're gonna go see her tonight and i
want you to look her in the eye and once
you put your hands on
the side of her face on both sides okay
okay and i want you to tell her i love
you with all my heart
i love our little baby delony this dude
on the radio thinks it's going to be a
boy but
i'm hoping it's a girl yeah and
i want us to go get some answers to our
relationship
sooner rather than later and so i'm
going to make some phone calls tomorrow
to find us a good
relationship counselor will you please
go with me
because i love you i know you love me
and we love this baby
and faith is super super important to me
it's not going to change
and your atheism may be really important
to you but i want to dig into where we
can
find common values for the sake of this
baby and if we need to call the
relationship then we need to call it
okay okay and that's hard what i just
asked you to do philip that's hard
that's that's you putting some either
ores man
but i'm telling you right now having a
baby
and still not knowing where you stand
relationally man just
is a recipe for a life of chaos okay
and a life of chaos is the last thing a
baby needs the baby needs two parents
that love
love and cherish each other and love and
love and cherish
him or her